all right so there are rumblings amidst
the world of Sony and amazon.com so I
bring you news of the new god of war so
I've heard whispers for months on a new
god of war game dubbed god of war floor
but no one really knew anything about it
other than it might be happening and now
thanks to the good people at amazon.com
or at least one person who loves us
enough to probably most definitely get
fired it has now been leaked to and
pulled from amazon.com as to what the
new god of war is and it has called god
of war ascension and is actually coming
out for the PlayStation 3 well I
expected if there was gonna be a god of
war fort was gonna come out for the
PlayStation 3 but God of War ascension
actually surprises me that it's coming
out for the PlayStation 3 because it's
actually a prequel to the God of War
games how the stuff usually goes the
main story games come out for the
consoles and the backstory comes out for
the portable systems it's almost
Scripture at this point usually
naysayers I said usually now I've heard
a lot of mixed feelings as to this god
of war ascension 1 because people wanted
to see what would happen after god of
war 3 I personally did and I was like
yeah 3 wrapped up pretty well I see it
as the conclusion I know they kind of
left it open a little bit but the dude
took out gods I don't know how you're
gonna beat that which almost brings me
to the point of God of War ascension
which is a prequel to the God of War
games in which case yeah how are you
gonna beat 3 3 was the pinnacle dude
like every situation every boss fight
you're like this is the most intense
that the God of War saga is ever gonna
get before God of War 1 are the stakes
really gonna be higher than any of the
other god of war games the trailer the
God of War ascension doesn't show any
gameplay whatsoever it just shows Kratos
chained up and a voice which sounds a
lot like Gaea from the God of War games
it's talking about oh yeah there was a
time before he was the ghost of Sparta
people take that as oh he's not gonna
have the blades of chaos but he got the
blades of chaos before he was called The
Ghost of Sparta someone god of war
ascension I believe he'll have the
blades of chaos you'll just be doing
what Ares tells you to do which you've
seen the backstory and God of War 1 he
did a lot of brutal [ __ ] under Ares
Bootheel which almost makes me think are
they showing too much I don't know if
you're like me but for me I like a
little bit of mystery to backstories I
like the fact that we got the backstory
to the Ghost of Sparta in the form of
these animated flashbacks when you show
100% of it you might just ruin all the
mystery that's their mystery holds
gravity and it's all I'm saying however
my thoughts on there being another god
of war game which is also a prequel is
this if they can do it and make it work
and make it good I'm down Kratos who's
coming back he's coming back for the
PlayStation 3 that just doesn't sound
like a bad thing to me kind of warranty
kick-ass granted this could be the
chapter where people are like that never
happened but at this point when we just
have a teaser trailer that shows no
gameplay whatsoever and just kind of
tells us when it takes place it's too
early to tell anything all we know for
certain is if you're job hunting I think
a spot at amazon.com has opened up
officially
but thanks dude for leaking that
information we love you for it so when
new god of war game is happening what do
you think about this information comment
below let me know and as always you feel
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more